at least three people have been killed
in a shooting attack in Thailand's
Capital several others have also been
injured we're just looking at some live
footage there when a gunman opened fire
in a mall in Bangkok the Prime Minister
says police arrested the suspected
gunman in a social media post police
said the suspect was just 14 years old
let's go to Tony Chang who's live for us
in Bangkok Tony bring us up to date with
what you know
we understand that at about uh 4 20 p.m
Bangkok time this afternoon shooting was
heard in the Paragon shopping center one
of the largest the most luxurious
shopping malls in Bangkok the law was
then evacuated police sent in they
conducted a search we understand that a
suspect has now been the team and
arrested the police say he is a 14 year
old boy who is using a pistol
bangkok's Emergency Services have
concerned to Al Jazeera that there were
three fatalities
four injuries that they know about so
far we understand them all is still
closed the police are sweeping through
prime minister has instructed Thailand's
police chief to to attend the scene of
the crime himself to provide a report
but we understand that the area is now
once again open to the public so it does
seem to be that the police are confident
that the immediate threat is now open
okay Tony many thanks Tony Chang our
correspondent they're in Bangkok about
the shooting
attack in a mall in Bangkok where three
people have been killed